we might react to something so we did
the tinder swindler breakdown yesterday
yesterday part one and we're gonna do a
second part on it because
that uh documentary even though you know
a lot of people are triggered by it it
does it
it's a fantastic showing of female
nature as to how uh men can kind of
deal with women and play to their
emotions to be able to get what they
want now obviously he did it in a
terrible way yeah
everybody are you ladies familiar with
this tinder swindler no yes explain that
please long story short guy uses charm
looks and affluence to con women into
giving him large sums of money he would
take money go to another girl show her
an extravagant lifestyle build rapport
with her start finessing her for money
and then go to girl number three et
cetera and just that's what we call in
the financial world a ponzi scheme
exactly yeah he didn't have any money he
got money from a lady he used that money
to prove to this person hey look at
those returns that i'm getting all right
boom boom boom and then basically just
like then the 2008 recession when
everybody wants their money back boom
who's left holding the hot potatoes so
what ended up happening with this guy so
yeah he ended up going to jail and he's
actually out now like he's on he's
living
in life and everything we pull him up
eric this guy tinder swindler yeah so
and netflix did a documentary on him
yeah he said you're suing them right now
though yeah him and his bodyguard are
suing it but we analyzed the video
they're suing netflix yeah yeah yeah for
information uh well yeah
yeah
so and where is he from do you know
israel he's israeli the israelites daddy
so um but yeah so we we broke it down
from a perspective to kind of let guys
know why this man was so successful from
a dating perspective yeah
he used his skills you know to commit a
crime but it does not you know it still
doesn't change the fact that he did have
skills in understanding female nature
where he was able to hit them at certain
emotional trigger points to be able to
get what he wanted which to be honest we
do a lot of the tactics he employed are
some of the tactics that women employ on
men but it's just very rare when one man
is able to reverse it and finesse a
woman hell when a man from that is a
woman it's a documentary and everyone
knows about it but when a woman finesses
a man nobody cares it's just you know
vanilla ice cream at that point
ladies if a guy
attractive ladies got your together
good looking dude he starts asking you
for money how do you respond
negative just that he's not not you're
not going to ask what it's for how can i
help what is it just like i'm not giving
you i just met you and you're asking me
for money why are you asking me for
money no that's for family friends
people you trust with years and years
and even then it's that comes with time
what do you think was so attractive
about this man that these women were
willing to give him did he know them for
an extended period of time was it like a
yeah like he wouldn't quit it kind of a
thing and then he would date them for
several months sometimes
a year plus and what he would do
he showed him a certain lifestyle he
sold him a dream basically did he have
money from the jump
or is it was it all just
ponzi schemes yeah he was i mean i don't
i don't know his credibility you could
google him and his family that's why
there was like you you could see that he
was the son of a diamond tycoon but that
was why right
right so he basically planted stories on
the internet uh he created validate who
he was yeah what was exactly online and
you could see it by articles you see it
by like his business and his planes
lifestyle yeah instagram so he had the
perception out there that he was
somebody so seeing that he approaches
you hey you know what i want you to be
my girl i want you to live with me want
you to take care of me sorry be with me
you're like okay you know what if i'm
his girlfriend and he needs help he's
rich so he'll pay me back that's a
little premise
how often do you think this happens i
mean well between men and women
obviously not yeah not as often but yeah
he pretty much perfectly backstopped his
his background you know we call that in
law enforcement you put undercover and
you got to have he has to have a certain
background so if you almost google him
or look up criminal history whatever
they're able to see okay he is who he
purports himself to be so we're going to
do business with him because he's a
criminal too so this guy pretty much
backstopped himself with you know
showing oh i'm part of this family i
have this lavish lifestyle look at my
instagram stories he's taking him out on
planes etc but the women don't know that
he actually procured that money from
another woman prior that he swung yeah i
want to play a game with you real quick
yeah sure because you know you used to
be in law enforcement yeah we gave the
good cop bad cop analogy yeah
be
put on your cop hat and tell me what was
wrong with what he did illegal whatever
and then put on your womanizer
wednesday's hat
this is what he did bro this is what we
need to like can you break that down for
me well i mean so here's the thing this
this all happened in europe so um but um
let's say it happened in the united
states this would be wire fraud because
the girls were sending him under money
under us you know concerned pretense so
that's easy federal offense i think it's
18 usc 1343 if i'm not mistaken um
which is why i fraud it's a very easy
catch-all probably you know um false
statements 1001 because i'm sure he had
to lie on certain documents etc uh you
know to get some of this money and yeah
man i mean if if this happened in the
united states definitely it would be
federal because he's traveling all over
the place that's nothing too he was
traveling to different countries in
europe as well so that's why it was very
difficult to go after him because he'd
be in one country for a couple you know
weeks or whatever then he moved to
another one etc and he was committing
crimes all over the place and obviously
every country has different laws
different regulations etcetera so
stealing from people that weren't women
as well
i think he was i think he was because i
towards the end of the documentary you
see like guys complaining as well but um
but yeah so from the law enforcement
perspective fraud all day wire fraud and
then from the womanizer wednesday
perspective the the dating side is um he
was able to play to women's emotions and
he was able to hit certain trigger
points that
were extremely how do i say this
sensitive so what he basically did for
one of the girls right was he told her
hey i want you to go apartment shopping
i want you to move in
and she spent like a whole day looking
at you know lavish apartments etc and
she's like oh i can feel it like she can
almost taste the fact that they're going
to be together you know in a living
together and then bam he drops on her
next day oh me and my friend got
assaulted my security guard i need help
blah blah blah and it would be very
strange for her to not help him after he
kind of had set this dream up so she was
in a vulnerable position because he had
sold her the dream and then he told her
hey spend a day going look at an
apartment so she could feel it and then
bang he reverses it pulls the rug from
underneath her hey i need 30 000 because
i can't use my cards anywhere they're
tracking me my life is in danger and she
started sending the money to him through
credit cards taking loans etc and you
got her
now based on the elaborate scheme this
guy put together and how he broke it
down
you know the guy says babe we're gonna
go we're gonna move it like these girls
these women are in love with him yeah